how tough is the job of simplifying a
robot so I I'd say in the early days the
the thing that made Boston
the researchers at Boston Dynamics
special is that we we worked on under
figuring out what that that Central
principle was and then building software
or machines around that principle and
that was not easy in the early days and
and it it took
um real expertise in understanding the
Dynamics of motion and feedback control
principles how to build and you know
with computers at the time how to build
a feedback control algorithm that was
simple enough that it could run in real
time at a thousand Hertz
and actually get that machine to work
um and that was not something everybody
was doing you know at that time
now the world's changing now and I I I
think the approach is to controlling
robots are going to change
um but it and that they're going to
become more broadly yet available
um but at the time there weren't many
groups who could really sort of work at
that principled level
uh with both the software and
and make the hardware work
and I'll and I'll say one other thing
about you're sort of talking about what
are the special things the other thing
was go it's okay it's good to break
stuff you know
um you know use the robots uh break them
repair them
um you know fix and repeat test fix and
repeat and that and that's also a core
principle that has become part of the
company
and it lets you be Fearless in your work
too often if you are working with a very
expensive robot maybe one that you
bought from somebody else or that you
don't know how to fix then you treat it
with kit gloves and you can't actually
make progress you have to be able to
break something and so I think that's a
been a a principle as well so just the
Linger on that psychologically how do
you deal with that because I remember I
had uh
uh I built a RC car with that some
uh it had some custom stuff like compute
on it and all that kind of stuff cameras
and uh because I didn't sleep much the
code I wrote has an issue where it
didn't stop the car and that the car got
confused and at full speed at like 20 25
miles an hour slammed into a wall
and I just remember sitting there alone
in the deep sadness
um
sort of
full of regret I think almost anger
um
uh but also like sadness because you
think about well these robots especially
for autonomous vehicles like like you
should be taking safety very seriously
even in these kinds of things but just
no good feelings
um and made me more afraid probably to
do this kind of experiments in the
future perhaps the right way to have
seen that is positively
like it's it's too it depends if you
could have built that car or or just
gotten another one right that would have
been the approach
um I remember
um when I got to grad school
um you know I got some training about
operating a lathe and a mill up in the
machine shop and I could start to make
my own parts and I remember breaking
some piece of equipment in the lab and
then realizing
because I maybe this was a unique part
and I couldn't go buy it and I realized
oh I can just go make it
that was an enabling feeling yeah then
you're not afraid it might take time it
might take more work than you thought it
was going to be required to get this
thing done
but you can just go make it and that's
freeing in a way that nothing else is